[Music]
fans have been waiting for the new
season of the mandalorian for quite a
while now the exciting season finale
which directly wetter the appetite for
more did not really contribute towards
bridging the waiting time well now actor
kol weathers has announced the start of
filming who by the way will be back in
his role as bounty hunter grief cargo
since last thursday the cameras are
finally running at full speed in order
to supply fans with fresh new content
promptly the production was actually
supposed to start earlier however the
shooting of the obi-wan series was still
obstructing the sets lots of fans are
wondering which characters might appear
in season 3 but disney is still being
very quiet about it however the return
of the villain muff gideon who is played
by giancarlo esposito is highly
anticipated since it will take some time
before we see the finished third season
of the mandalorian you can all the more
look forward to earlier releases from
the star wars universe next up is a
series of the book of boba fett which is
scheduled for release on disney plus
later this year starting december 29th
the marvel series one division appeared
on disney's own streaming platform
disney plus at the beginning of the year
the series was extremely well received
by fancy critics but it was clear all
along that one division was conceived as
a mini-series and therefore no second
season was to be produced despite this
this series will continue with new
content in the form of a spin-off as
variety reported a few days ago the plot
will primarily revolve around the
character agatha harkness and initially
a very innocent neighbor who rapidly
shows great interest in wellness powers
as the end of the series reveals wanda
ultimately triumphs over agatha and
leaves her behind in west view it's
quite possible that the spin-off will
pick up right at this point the ride has
announced that this series will be
filled with black humor and that
catherine hahn will once again play the
title character there might also be an
attempt to venture into agatha's past as
she's been alive for a few hundred years
after all behind the scenes jack
schaefer is handling the script as well
as the production allegedly lead actress
catherine han has already signed a
contract with marvel which foresees that
her character will appear in further
film projects we are definitely eager to
find out how marvel will realize the one
division spin-off based on agatha
harkness and will of course let you know
as soon as there is a first release date
or any more news
marvels guardians of the galaxy 2 was
released almost 4 years ago at the end
of the hit movie a lot spoke in favor of
an upcoming appearance of the character
adam warlock and as a now confirmed new
cast edition reveals a well-known
hollywood star is to take over the role
of the artificially created human this
refers to 28 year old will poulter who
celebrated among other movies success in
the maze runner and black mirror banda
snatch and has now been cast in
guardians of the galaxy 3. the bad guy
adam warlock was mentioned in the second
part's post-credits scene by the high
priestess aisha in the same breath she
spoke about how strong warlock was and
that their guardians ought to destroy
him once and for all well sounds like a
worthy opponent for the guardians we are
excited to see how poultry will play the
role of the villain regardless the
release date for guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 is still a long time away as the
marvel blockbuster won't be released
until may 5th 2023
just about everyone knows fortnite some
people love it others not so much
nevertheless everyone agrees that the
video game has generated incredible hype
this could now lead to an upcoming
fortnite movie according to reports game
developer epic game has already hired
three lucasfilm employees in terms of
staff one of them is jason mcgatlin who
may sound familiar to someone as the
producer of the more recent star wars
movies as such epic games could now
establish itself in the film industry
after apple has made it difficult for
the game developer to achieve further
sales success with ios devices due to
apple preventing users from downloading
the game however it's hard to say
whether it will actually become a movie
in the end although it would hardly
surprise
anyone the standard of the gigantic the
lord of the rings amazon series is to be
the most effortful and expensive series
of all time fans of the talking universe
can't even look forward to becoming
acquainted with the folk in the upcoming
series that has not yet been touched
upon on film it is about the harfords
who were actually no more than the
direct ancestors of the well-known
hobbits more precisely they are one of
the three tribes of hobbits that were
very different from the other halfling
tribes but later in the mingled in an
interview with bbc british actor lenny
henry confirmed the appearance of the
harfords thus he said they were a
multicultural tribe with a wide range of
ethnic groups in tolkien's book there is
talk of hobbits with brown skin and
significantly smaller body size than the
other tribes since the lord of the rings
series is known to be set in the second
age of middle earth it'll be interesting
to see in what way the hard foots will
be incorporated since the tribe does not
show up in the books until the third age
well at least they were mentioned there
for the first time based on the canon it
is not clear whether they already lived
before the third age meaning that the
series creators are probably closing a
gap in the books here anyhow you can see
the final outcome from september 2nd
2022 on amazon prime video
the third season of netflix hit series u
is now available to watch shortly before
the start of the season the streaming
giant announced another aspect in a
video namely the production of a fourth
season including joe actor ben badgley
in other words the mind-boggling plot
surrounding stalker joe goldberg will
carry on for a while longer as the
antagonist seems to be becoming
increasingly manic and mentally
disturbed netflix has not revealed a
precise release date for season 4 but
given the festive bell ringing in the
teaser many fans are speculating on a
christmas 2022 release whether that's
actually the case we will hopefully find
out soon
since june at least actor timothy
chalamet has been one of the most sought
after young actors in hollywood now the
25 year old is going the extra mile by
taking on the lead role in a children's
book adaption we're talking about
charlie and the chocolate factory or
rather the prequel with the name wonka
it will be about the young willy wonka
who is still far from becoming the
well-known eccentric factory owner on
instagram chalamet went ahead and shared
a picture that shows him in the new lead
role you can see a much younger willy
wonka who especially in terms of
appearance is not yet reminiscent of the
colorful entrepreneur but more of a
normal citizen of his time which of
course fits ideally into the atmosphere
of the prequel in addition an
appropriate caption is given by the
actor in which he points out that he can
hardly stand the suspense he is joined
by other actors of distinction in the
cast including sally hawkins olivia
coleman jim carter and no less a figure
than rowan atkinson the release date for
wonka has already been set for march 17
2023
last but not least we recommend the new
scream trailer which you can find in
best quality on our channel as usual
this isn't funny amber
attacks so far do you have a gun i'm
sydney prescott of course i have a gun
something about this one just feels
different
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is going to keep coming
for you
[Music]
you ready
for this
[Music]
it's an honor
right before halloween you should make
sure not to miss it
[Music]
foreign